Speaker 1: It's time for Friday Feedback,
The mailbag.
The Friday feedback.
Someone actually wrote to me saying it should
really be called Friday Apple Bags, which
relates to a whole other thing from the vaccine
era.
Anyway, we don't even need to get into that.
That's probably outside the scope of today's
conversation.
If you have something to say and many of you
do, you can email info at David Packman dot
com.
Please keep them polite.
Not everyone we look at today will be polite.
Be aware that as you are furiously typing
comments on YouTube, they might be selected
and end up in the Friday feedback.
You never know.
And Reddit posts and so on and so forth.
It all might end up there.
All right, Let's start with today's first
one from YouTube user John Cherokee, who says,
Yep, Tucker Carlson was an American hero and
I hope he will get his own show where they
can't fire him because his message is very
important.
In addition to that, Taylor Green is an American
hero.
She's basically standing virtually alone,
basically virtually alone in Congress defending
the rights of the American people.
This is a big fan, not only of Tucker Carlson,
but of Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
Not a single punctuation element in this entire
message unless you count the apostrophe on
she's.
But certainly no sentences.
Listen, this is one of those things where
we all have to pick our battles and the battles
I pick on a podcast and YouTube channel and
the battles you pick at the Thanksgiving table
and that your sibling picks at the Memorial
Day barbecue, which is upcoming, right?
Whatever battles we all pick might be different.
And for me, I am not now going to choose the
battle of trying to convince someone who believes
that Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Tucker Carlson
are the height of American patriotism, that
they are wrong.
That is not a battle that I am going to pick
right now.
So we're going to move on.
But these folks exist, and that's always important
to remember.
Speaker 3: Dee Dee.
Speaker 1: 2023.
Dee Dee says L.O.L.
I can't believe you all are applauding high
taxes for everyone in some obscure version
of fairness.
That doesn't help you at all.
In fact, it damages you when the company you
work for moves to a different country to operate
or cuts costs by changing your health care
benefits to a cheaper one or flat out lays
you off because you aren't very efficient.
So dumb.
You know, I understand.
And I'm in agreement with the reality that
if any tax gets too high, it starts to have
an impact that is usually not ideal.
And with most policy, this isn't unique to
taxes in general, with policy in general,
with life.
When you think about the extreme tales of
normal distribution, you start to see distortions.
Take, for example, like exercise.
If you are completely sedentary and sit all
day at a desk and then at home, and then in
your car and then watching TV, you know, physical
exercise, you're on one tail end of physical
exercise and that's bad for you.
On the other hand, if you become completely
obsessed with exercise to the point that you
can't hold the job and you're destroying your
body by working out 18 hours a day and sleeping
for six or whatever, right at the extremes
of these bell curves, there are problems.
And so 0% taxes would be a problem because
we can't have functioning infrastructure and
then 100% taxes as well.
And so we're all kind of operating in the
gray area.
But what is missed by lots of these people
who write stuff like this are they don't get
that most corporations are pass through entities
like S Corporations LLC and others and that
the so-called business tax rate from which
there are endless loopholes applies to C corporations.
But again, I'm sort of like trying to explain
this to somebody who's not willing to listen
anyway, but I am in agreement that taxes shouldn't
be too high, and how we define that probably
differs between us.
Rocky Road said Look for Real As a 100% diehard
Trump supporter, I'd like one of David Portman's
audience to explain this to me.
How has Biden's first term been Anything other
than a complete disaster?
I'm not trying to troll.
I'm not looking to insult.
I'm just 100% puzzled by this.
Well, I like to apply something called the
burden of proof in these situations.
I would love to hear from Rocky Road what
elements of Joe Biden's presidency make it
a disaster in?
Nation Reduction Act reasonably sized does
some good things.
Changes to student lending.
Small changes to health care access.
Stock market is doing fine.
Unemployment lowest since 1969.
Inflation coming down.
No new wars as they always like to say.
You may say, well, but Russia invaded Ukraine.
Okay.
Yeah, but Biden didn't start that war.
You know, you make the case make the case
for the Biden disaster, because I look around
and I see wages up 4.4% over the last year.
Inflation down, stocks, okay.
New jobs.
Things seem like sort of all right, nothing's
perfect.
We haven't solved a whole bunch of systemic
and structural issues, but sort of like seems
like things are going okay.
This was a meme posted to our subreddit.
I don't know how many of you have been following
the Steven Crowder situation where Steven
Crowder is a right wing talker and he's getting
a divorce and surveillance of security camera
footage was released in which he's berating
his wife and it's okay.
Here is conservatives struggling with conflicting
notions.
The Steven Crowder video is an invasion of
his privacy and shouldn't be blocked and should
be blocked, rather, versus arguing that Hunter
Biden's penis pictures should be publicly
available.
Yeah, they've really gotten themselves into.
Now, of course, you know what they will say,
right?
Sometimes on the left we think we really got
them now.
We really got them.
They will simply say that Hunter the Hunter
Biden laptop story, which included the penis
pictures, is more politically relevant.
To American politics than what Steven Crowder
has to say because Hunter is Joe Biden's son
or whatever.
We've already debunked it in the sense that
Hunter Biden has nothing to do with the Biden
administration.
And Stephen Crowder also has nothing to do
with the Biden administration.
So, you know, a little something for everyone
there.
Descartes walks into a pub.
Says who could have predicted stripping away
rights and banning books would drive away
voters?
Yeah, this is tongue in cheek, but it really
didn't seem that Florida Republicans and other
Republicans understood.
That the Anti-woke crusade that they are waging
isn't super popular with much of America,
that much of a majority of America is coming
down on the side of Disney, on the side of
drag shows existing.
And you can choose whether you bring your
kid or not, dealing with structural problems
that affect trans people.
Most of the country is on the so-called woke
side.
And so as I've said before, a lot of these
are good ways to raise some money.
In primaries, in local races.
But as far as national campaigns, it's not
at all evident to me that this anti-woke approach
book banning canceling all the stuff the right
is doing is going to work well.
But we will see.
We have an election coming up from YouTube.
23 mistakes says perhaps telling half the
voters that they no longer make decisions
about their own bodies has something to do
with falling poll numbers.
Same idea.
You look at abortion, you look at polling
on Roe v Wade, and you see that since Roe
v Wade, the Roe v Wade era started started
50 years ago, support for abortion being legal
in most cases has only gone up.
And it reached its highest point right around
the time that the Supreme Court did away with
Roe v Wade.
And it did play a role in the November of
2022 midterms.
Maybe not as big a role as it would have played
if it had been closer in time to the election.
It was, you know, some months, but.
You look at the polling and you look at opinion
surveys about what Americans want, and you
see most Americans do believe abortion should
be legal most of the time.
So then why would you have an entire political
movement, Social conservatism based around
ending and banning abortion doesn't seem to
make sense.
We will see if they suffer even more as a
result of that in 2024.
And of course, I hope that they do consequences
for actions.
It's a beautiful thing.
Lastly, Pam Hall says very disappointed in
Packman, who had endorsed Williamson on another
of his podcasts.
Why he is throwing her under the bus now over
a gaffe is the real question.
Please, please, please criticize me for things
I said I never endorsed.
Marianne Williamson.
My position on Marianne Williamson has not
changed since I learned about her since I
became woke to Marianne Williamson.
Very nice person, has great empathy and shares
many of my broader ideals and is not interesting
to me as a presidential candidate for many
reasons that I've gone over, including lack
of relevant experience in a number of different
areas.
Previous statements that I find completely
antithetical to my worldview about everything
from depression to other things.
I don't know that the problem is.
I simplify, simplify, simplify, to try to
be to make it impossible to be misunderstood.
But then I don't provide enough context.
So it causes a problem.
And then when I go nuance, expand nuance context,
people don't listen to the whole thing and
then they go, You endorsed her on another
podcast.
What are you talking about?
What on earth are you talking about?
Endorsed?
In what sense?
What does that even mean?
So listen, Marianne Williamson should run.
She is running.
It's not up to me.
Anybody who wants to run should run.
I would like I would prefer the DNC have debates.
They're not going to.
It has nothing to do with me.
The DNC is not going to have debates because
why would you do something that could jeopardize
the campaign of whoever is sort of like the
de facto nominee?
Doesn't matter who it is.
They're not going to have debates.
I would like to see debates.
And you would just have to figure out what
polling threshold would be required to make
it into the Democratic debate.
Would it be 4%, 6%, 8% in the polling?
I don't know.
But you'd have to find some threshold.
And I would love to see a debate with Joe
Biden.
Marianne Williamson, you know, Bobby Kennedy
Junior, to the extent that he's a Democrat
and he's running and has polling support,
which he does in some polls, put him on a
stage.
That's great.
I think it's fantastic.
Am I supporting Marianne Williamson for president?
No, I'm not.
But that doesn't mean I don't think she should
run or that she should be silenced or whatever
the case may be.
Criticize me if you disagree with what I actually
believe.
Not random musings that are about things I've
never said.
Info it.
David Pack Mint.com.
You might be featured in next week's Friday
Feed bag, Feedback Friday, etc..
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up at join time.com.
We will see you then for Monday.